- WHAT DO WE DO?
THEY TOLD US AT THE STATION
TO COME DOWN HERE AND FILL TIME,
BUT, UH, THERE'S
NO STORY HERE.
- IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD,
THERE'S ALWAYS A STORY.
HERE, GIMME THE NAME
OF A MYTHICAL CREATURE.
- MYTHICAL CREATURE?
I DON'T--
- TRUST ME.
- UH, I DON'T--A PEGASUS.
- PEGASUS, PERFECT.
JUST ROLL,
WATCH, AND LEARN.
- THEY CAN STAY IN MY HOUSE
IF THEY WANT TO--
- HI, THERE. RICK NICHOLSBY,
CHANNEL SIX NEWS.
WE'VE HAD REPORTS
OF A PEGASUS IN THE AREA.
HAS ANYBODY SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT?
- AW, YEAH, MAN,
I SEEN A PEGASUS.
I SEEN IT, YEAH, EVERY DAY.
- I SEES IT TOO, MAN.
WE BOTH SEE
THAT PEGASUS, DOG.
- YEAH, I SAW IT
WITH MY OWN TWO EYES, MAN.
THAT HORSE HAD
A BIG OLD SNAKE HEAD--
- NAW, MAN, IT AIN'T
GOT NO SNAKE HEAD, FOOL.
Y'ALL, THAT--THAT HORSE
HAD SOME BIG WINGS, MAN.
- YEAH, YEAH.
- THAT'S SOME FLYING [bleep].
- YEAH, THAT HORSE
HAD BIG OLD WINGS.
MAN, LIKE TWO
SETS OF WINGS, YEAH.
Y'ALL SEE THE PEGASUS?
all: YEAH.
- EVERYBODY UP IN HERE
SEEN THE PEGASUS, MAN.
- CURIOSITY HAS
BROUGHT OUT LARGE CROWDS
TO SEE THE ALLEGED PEGASUS IN
THIS SOUTH LENNOX NEIGHBORHOOD.
- LOOK, THERE IT IS.
- I'M GONNA FIND IT,
BREAK IT,
AND THEN RIDE IT
TO THE PEGASUS TREASURE.
- RESIDENTS SAY THE CREATURE
RESEMBLES THIS AMATEUR SKETCH.
- KICKED THE [bleep]
OUT OF MY CAR.
CITY'S GOTTA PAY
FOR THAT [bleep] TOO.
I AIN'T GOT NO COVERAGE
FOR NO PEGASUS, BITCH.
- HE LAND ON MY ROOF, MAN.
LOOK AT MY ROOF, MAN.
HE BUSTED IT UP.
HE BUSTED
THE WHOLE THING UP, MAN.
YEAH, HE BEEN--HE BEEN--HE BEEN
SITTING UP THERE EVERY DAY.
- WHILE MANY REVEL
IN THE POSSIBILITY
OF SEEING
THE WINGED HORSE,
OTHERS ARE NOT
SO WELCOMING.
- I JUST KNOW THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
WOULD BE BETTER
IF THAT PEGASUS
IS PUT DOWN.
- I TELL YOU THIS: GOD AIN'T
PUTTING NO WINGS ON NO HORSE.
- NOW, SEE, IF THIS WAS
A WHITE NEIGHBORHOOD,
ANIMAL CONTROL
WOULD BE UP IN HERE
WITH A PEGASUS TRAP.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY CAN'T TAKE OUR PEGASUS.
THIS IS OUR PEGASUS.
- PEGASUS UP IN
THIS MOTHER[bleep]!
- HEY, MAN, WHY YOU
INTERRUPTING ME?
I'M TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT THE PEGASUS.
- [bleep] YOU!
- HEY!
DON'T BE DISRESPECTING PEGASUS!
- I LOVE PEGASUS!
- YES, WE'RE HERE LIVE
ON THE SCENE IN SOUTH LENNOX,
WHERE RIOTS HAVE BROKEN OUT
OVER THE ALLEGED APPEARANCE
OF A FLYING HORSE.